hey guys it's a Sam I'm here with a very
special announcement that we just
released face mask on our human website
so for every mass that is sold we would
be donating one to a medical worker so
please make sure to check us out our
website is www.pevs.com Plex set of
assumptions and stereotypes surrounding
the idea of virginity where did these
impressions come from the media religion
or popular culture does this see really
anything about a person as you watch
this episode of odd man out and pick the
tumors
think of what prior judgment is from
your decision we brought together seven
versions
I'm a virgin I'm a virgin
I'm a virgin I'm a virgin two of them
are liars
if the group discovers both the liars
they'll split a cash prize if any of the
liars survive they win the entire price
who is the odd Menem why why are you
guys virgins I'm a Christian okay the
fact that there were four Christians
kind of caught me off guard so I kind of
thought that one of the Christians
wasn't a virgin I grew up in a
conservative middle-eastern family so we
just didn't grow up talking about that
so I never felt comfortable and I wasn't
really confident in myself I'm from like
a Catholic family so like Filipino
Catholic family there's no way that I
could not ever have the thing plus I'm
all old
I'm serious I'm demisexual it's like
kind of on a spectrum but yeah she
looked a little mysterious and before
the round started we were inform that
there were two moles and she didn't
really have a reaction to that I voted
for Lea because she didn't say anything
and also she was the oldest she didn't
really give us much to go off of so I
[Music]
think it makes sense that people voted
me out because I'm older I don't think
there should be that stigma on older
people like if you're older you had to
have sex but it makes sense to me
everybody had their first kiss I was 18
who knows my kiss first kiss he said
that he lost his first kiss and that was
just a red flag in my head because I was
like I wouldn't say it like that I was I
was in elementary school all the guys
were like talking about your first kiss
yet I was like high school and find out
oh I guess I was way ahead of everybody
I mean I've done like until I stopped
further than kissing like oral sex like
I don't know what you guys consider like
true sex but with my ex that was like a
purely lustful relationship so like yeah
was he come like coming on to you and
you were just like it was more like
because we were so like any
other's faces and it would just kind of
like happened and then right before like
you know it would have crossed that line
I was like wait wait hold on wait we can
we just take a break because he was also
a virgin he broke up with me had sex
with someone else we got back together
and he told me and then we broke up
again
Jocelyn mentioned a lot of close times
they were like losing like almost losing
her virginity and like maybe she I
caught maybe she was slipping I was
dating someone that wasn't saved yeah
and yeah I really mind that brings me
down yeah when there's not Jesus in the
center yeah it's a and it's not when
your your relationship learn you're not
focused on Christ relationship for the
other kind of it brings you down yeah
Ivan mentioned something about losing
his kiss I didn't want her but I had to
he was pretty like timid and I just felt
like he wasn't giving enough details to
what he was saying
I genuinely tried to talk and like say
my things out but everyone was going
over me I just like shrank more down I
wish I talked more what are some
stereotypes that you guys think at my
work the other day like two of my
coworkers are like talking in the back
and then I walked up and they're like oh
Rachel's here we can't talk about this
stuff because like she's too like
angelic and I was like guys come on like
I know about everything if people think
that like as a virgin that I'm like
afraid of sex but best believe
wedding-night going nowhere now my
weekend I feel like for me is that
people immediately assume I'm religious
and waiting for a marriage that's
actually not the case room yeah I feel
like a little like I can't relate to you
guys cuz I'm not technically waiting for
marriage but I'm waiting to have a solid
relationship yeah like I just want to be
totally completely comfortable with him
I would say other stereotypes that
people have that bother me that we have
no social skills or that we're not
attractive or we are super introverted
it's like there's no right time to have
sex everyone's on their own path and you
know when the time comes it comes my
religion is the main reason why I'm
waiting but also it just it makes sense
to wait to share that with somebody
that's the only person that's gonna
share that with you that's like that's
just something really special and they
go beyond religion yeah everybody has
told me like I had a really crappy time
the first time so I've gotten my heart
broken just like in a relationship and I
feel like if I had that like loss to
somebody like that would hurt me yeah
ten times man
I hate that it's called like losing your
virginity like I don't want to lose it I
want to give it yeah yeah thank you cuz
when you lose something you don't intend
to lose something so in
you lose your virginity it's like you
never intended to like give yourself to
someone sexually and I'm willingly and
like I want to give my virginity to
someone because it's something that's
sacred and it's something that's really
important to me what you're saying about
like other forms of sex because stories
are pretty so yeah like I I also
struggled with pornography and but God
really freed me from that as well it
messed with my mind really did it gives
you this fake outlook on what sex is
yeah it's not real it's not sex like
that's just actors like I think for when
guys gonna do that stuff it makes them
think of women as an object in Italy and
that they're just to be used for their
pleasure and I just I think it's awful
and porn is so racist and sexist and
yeah I mean the videos I've seen online
it's like it's always like black dude
black girl like asian girl whatever blah
blah like it's trying to gain views
through people's ethnicities and it
really promotes stereotypes my parents
didn't tell me to like wait until
marriage to have sex but they taught me
especially my mom like she was like let
your own damn life first like explore
get educated become successful then like
worry about men like I just feel like
I've had not a lot of drama in my life
because I haven't dated good honestly
like I'm really successful when I'm in a
really great place and I learned to love
myself first before I'm gonna love
someone else
yeah I have a question for the
Christians I mean I don't have mine
oxide I jammed my finger but I have a
purity ring do you guys like have
anything to like no I think you need to
show it it's not she brought up purity
ring's and I feel like that's something
that not too many Christians do in
nowadays so I thought maybe she was
trying to pretend to be a Christian and
that was one way yeah I'm allergic to
metal
specific for me so like I just don't
even like yeah I made these earrings so
like I know it's enough other than that
like I don't message I just got these
vibes from him that he had sex before it
was like there were so many religious
people in the group and I was like
trying to get rid of one of them and
security ring made me choose her the
most linear guy is it's not me raise
your hand if you think that the more
listed in the box
and you would like to continue the game
yeah we sex like especially for you guys
cuz you grew up religious no sex like a
taboo yeah topic in your house like did
they ever talk it like did you get the
birds and the bees talk I mean it was
treated with respect but not it wasn't
like swept under the rug it was talked
about but it wasn't it like yeah do it
like super open about it yeah yeah they
were like here's what it is here's what
it's for we kind of expect you to to
oblige with that but yeah I want to
bounce back to what you said about like
alternative like what is virginity no
it's like is is like oral sex is that
cuz some people are like people are like
yeah give me a hand job could be sex
yeah it's like I guess that depends on a
server sooner I would say I because so I
think the penetration I think it just
depends on the good motivation or I
don't even know I don't know if it's not
one definition then it's like too like
loose yeah yeah it yeah subjectivity is
weird yeah are you gonna ask like you're
viewing like sex like sex education like
do you guys believe in abstinence is
like wait wait but like teaching that
ice cream school yeah I mean I would
teach all of them yeah I teach
everything but stress abstinence cuz
that's the only like in my opinion
that's the safest abstinence is not
gonna help the problem like you need to
teach safe sex and provide condoms and
teach
girls about birth control so that
they're not getting pregnant too young
not having the resources and you know
avoiding abortions and all that yeah I
think you should teach that but just
stress abstinence don't can today
absences this doesn't non-religious
person yeah I get that
I don't agree with you on that but like
respectfully disagree like for sure
industry teach syrup like I literally
I'm just like to each their own if you
do you do like that's what makes you
happy like this isn't I don't like the
red lights Rachel I noticed was sharing
a lot less than she had in the previous
rounds the whole abstinence thing
waiting until marriage
like his the only answer for him just
kind of made me feel like he was playing
the game too hard
[Music]
raise your hand if you're certain that
the more listed in the box and you would
like to continue the game I definitely
learned that my version radar is
completely off I am a born-again
Christian so my strategy going to the
game was to have the mindset that I do
now
which is kind of twisting my truth so
everything I said had a lot of truth
face to it also identifies me sexual um
when I lost my virginity it was before I
came to terms with it she kind of
coerced me it's like if you loved me
you'd like lose like you'd have sex with
me so when we broke up uh so when we
broke up it like affected me oh hi
eventually in college from like accost
me it was just like oh I'm ace and I was
like oh can you tell me about that
nicely described it I was just like oh
that's that's me
I hope someone I find someone that
understands what identify what I won't
force me to do anything I if you're out
there
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for supporting human good this is
the link to our website and don't forget
to follow us on Instagram and I hope
you're all staying safe tear in
quarantine this looks like a dance but
it's okay
I'm Jewish I'm Jewish
I'm Jewish I am Jewish I'm Jewish I'm
Jewish I am Jewish one of them is a liar
[Music]